hey 42 here the corner of the universe
that we live in is pretty quiet
there's nothing nearby likely to explode
swallowers or poor just generally try to
ruin our weekend but that's not to say
that there aren't some terrifying things
out there in the darkness that would
make you cower under your bed mr.
Fluffles and hope that the solar system
is just how you left it when you finally
crawl out again today we're looking at
some of the most terrifying monsters we
have ever discovered in the universe
brontophobia is the fear of lightning
and there are estimated to be twenty
four thousand lightning related deaths a
year
a typical lightning strike is about
thirty thousand pounds and even these
can vaporize metal and fuse sand into
glass but a team at the University of
Toronto have found the highest
electrical current that has ever been
measured somewhere out in space
measuring an enormous 10 to the 18 ohms
which is the same as a trillion of our
lightning bolts here on earth so what's
causing this massive surge of
electricity has for been on the steroids
again it's actually down to a gigantic
black hole of the core of a galaxy
called free sea free zero free the
magnetic fields that it produces are
moving and interacting and this is what
generates the massive electrical surge
like a super-sized dynamo and if we do
manage to all avoid being struck by
lightning that doesn't mean were safe
for more burning up like Walmart on
Black Friday in every galaxy there are
stars moving so quickly that they are
able to escape the pull of gravity and
rays through space unchecked stars much
like those of Hollywood are single much
less than you might think about half the
stars in our galaxy form a binary pair
where two stars orbit around each other
in a beautiful cosmic dance us or none
fortunately has to sit on its own in the
corner like the ugly in utter dunce
so sometimes when these binary pairs are
dragged towards the large black hole lot
always sits at the center of every
galaxy one of the stars can be ripped
free and hold off at a speed of 10,000
kilometers per second
the other is swallowed into the black
hole like when that lonely fat kid finds
the buffet table and they've such a
rogue star came anywhere near our solar
system there's not very much we could do
to stop it as it burned us up and its
enormous gravity pulled everything out
of orbit the likelihood of this is
fortunately very low though so if you do
see a bright dot in the sky don't stop
doing your homework and wait for the
world to end just yet it's probably just
an aeroplane or a really shiny pigeon or
something at some point our galaxy is
going to collide with the Andromeda
galaxy so make sure that you don't put
anything in the die for about three
billion years in the future you know
just in case when the two do combine the
black holes at their centers will even
merge into a supermassive black hole or
they will form a binary pair just like
the stars we mentioned earlier the
compressed matter around the
supermassive black holes becomes a
quasar which stands for quasi-stellar
radio source since they emit similar
electromagnetic radiation two stars
including gradient waves and visible
light they are incredibly bright you
need a hundred Milky Way's just too much
them just one quasar is enough to use up
our entire stockpile of sunglasses but
the huge large quasar group who names
this crap is a string of 73 quasars that
spreads four billion light-years across
making it the second largest structure
in the known universe the biggest of
which is a fun silly named Hercules
Corona borealis great wall
okay that's slightly better a group of
14 gamma-ray burst walls which are very
bright objects caused by dying stars
both of these gigantic monsters you will
want to avoid if you value your eyesight
sometimes when you have a massive star
it goes supernova and collapses under
its own weight and ends up as a neutron
star which are hyper dense balls about
11 kilometers across yet they can have
the mass of double our Sun how is this
how can you fit that much into such a
ridiculously small space
our neutron stars made by Ikea no there
is a scientific explanation as anyone
who has ever tried to pack a week's
clothes into their hand look it will
tell you if you push things together
that tightly they will push back those
same people will probably tell you it
wasn't worth the 11 pounds they saved on
luggage fees when their underwear and
spare tea bags burst all over security
control the neutron stars are
unsurprisingly made up of neutrons when
you pack them together that tightly the
only thing that stops it collapsing into
a black hole is this repulsion between
the particles which only becomes
powerful at such immense densities a
neutron star is so dense that just a
matchbox sized amount would weigh about
13 million tons on earth occasionally
these neutron stars become magnetized
which isn't a Pokemon where they produce
such a powerful magnetic field that they
even alter the vacuum of space around
them they are the most powerful magnets
in the universe so if you do visit one
remember to leave behind your credit
card and take out your nipple piercings
ouch
stars are messy little things not only
do they pump out a wide spectrum of
electromagnetic radiation but when they
are finished they often leave behind
huge clouds of dust called a nebula if
you were up close you probably wouldn't
notice it since it spread out more
friendly than any artificial vacuum
we've ever made on earth but from far
away enough we can spot what remains of
the star and if we watch for long enough
we'll probably see surrounding solar
systems complaining about their messy
neighbour as it starts to gobble up
their planets these nebulae can be
hundreds of light-years across a while
Sark lives on earth are often fat cute
and fluffy these space giants form
strains and twisted shapes that truly
look like monsters of the universe just
seven thousand light-years away within
the Eagle Nebula there are the towering
space worms known as the pillars of
creation these dark clouds will slowly
draw together and form the stars of the
where their simple hydrogen will heat
and eventually produce all the rich and
complicated material like we see here on
earth how about a real monster this time
just when you for that space was quiet
as a grave you hear a horrifying mode
it's a zombie star I'm not sure you can
defeat this one with a cricket bat to
the head
so probably vestiges head down the
Winchester bother doors
and hope it doesn't find you this is the
result of a binary pair of stars where
one of them is a white dwarf a white
dwarf is similar to a neutron star
except that the original star didn't
have enough must who fully collapse into
a neutron star so you're left with a
ball of mostly carbon and oxygen
there's no fusion reaction going on
anymore so it's just a corpse left out
on the porch slowly losing its heat but
when you have a binary pair it's
possible that the white dwarf will reach
energy of its partner and slowly regain
the mass it needs to come alive again
kick-starting the fusion reaction
probably resulting in a final rampaging
supernova such stars are fittingly known
as zombie stars it's a similar story for
vampire stars also known as blue
stragglers we discovered stars I seem to
be much hotter than those in their local
area and when it comes to stars hotter
means younger but since they all formed
from the same nebula how can this happen
well like with the zombie stars we think
one star sucks the life out of another
giving it that youthful glow that we all
long for so put down your quinoa cream
pour away that disgusting kale juice and
sub going to bloody Zumba class all you
need to do is eat a star and lastly a
weird one
if you were an interstellar explorer
living got vacuum dried protein bars and
drinking your own recycled liquids
there are probably times when you stare
out into the frozen blackness and think
god dammit I need a drink
well ask and ye shall receive
Sagittarius b2 is a 150 light years stop
this dust cloud within the Milky Way
contains vast vast quantities of ethyl
formate which give it the unique flavor
of raspberries and roe there's also
enough ethyl alcohol to get everyone on
earth drunk for trillions of years so if
NASA are really worried about the public
losing interest in the space program
just tell them that for a few billion
dollars we're going to build a ship and
go and rained God's liquor cabinet maybe
this is why we've yet to meet alien life
they're all waiting for us to join them
at the gigantic bar in the sky with all
these monsters creeping around in space
perhaps we should be grateful that all
we have to deal with is one son the
occasional asteroid and all those other
weird monsters I mean people that we've
managed to get stuck on this little rock
with I think we can all raise a Roman
raspberry to that right thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42 if you think
making a murderer was shocking you ain't
seen nothing yet
it's estimated that every year in Japan
hundreds of people are wrongfully
convicted for crimes they didn't commit
there are hidden oil wells all over Los
Angeles these secret oil wells are
hidden right in plain sight somewhere
next to schools and shopping malls